[Musique]
papa
et vous
c'est japon n'est pas
la vie
[Musique]
sa série ses chansons matinée
deschamps
[Musique]
il
j c
mal bruce s'en va-t-en guerre aux
mironton me rendormir antenne mal bruce
s'en va-t-en guerre
je sais que rob viendra voir qu'est ce
que c'est
casimir veux tu cites glisse cessé de
chanter ça me fait gonfler les oreilles
nos cinq ans vieira
il reviendra à pâques à me rendormir
anthony antennes il reviendra à patins
ou à la trinité
casimir dix mois casimir qui ce monsieur
malroux dont tu parle tout le temps je
ne le connais pas léonard tué en
ignorant et quand est-ce qu'il viendra
monsieur malbrouck un tu pourras me le
présenter peut-être tu sais les amis de
mes amis sont mes amis mais il n'existe
pas c'est le héros d'une vieille chanson
française que je lis ma prise très bien
très bien très ignorants comme tu es tu
ne s'est peut-être pas non plus pourquoi
je chante cette chanson
1 et bien c'est parce que c'est bientôt
pâques un et je suppose que tu ne sais
pas non plus ce qu'est paca pour être
bon et bien là qu'un c'est le jour où
les cloches viennent au dessus de l'île
et pondent des oeufs dans tout le jardin
non non tu es fou casimir ce ne sont pas
les cloches qui pondent des oeufs
ce sont les poules mais non écoute je
sais bien placé pour le savoir enfin
j'adore les oeufs mais j'adore encore
plus les poulets coûte 1 habituellement
peut-être mais le jour de pâques ce sont
les cloches et il est jeune se casse pas
en tendant à non non non parce que ce
jour-là ce jour là bas ils doivent être
exceptionnellement solide à des les
cloches compterait attention de laisser
tomber les eaux délicatement dans les
buissons casimir tu es sûr tu ne manques
pas de moi ah non absolument pas mais
alors ils font vite regarder si les
clans j'arrive louis débit chez nous
peut-être 100
tout près d'ici envie de parler manger
quoi passons vite
c'est une très bonne idée quoi penser
sont peut-être déjà là à temps alors on
regarde bien fait attention aux nuages
qui risque de les cacher pour l'instant
je ne vois rien attends je vais voir ben
alors oh la la
oulalala ouhlala toi qu'est-ce qui vient
quasiment une énorme claque au vent elle
vient sans doute pour te voir un petit
mon secours au matin à pois bleus quoi
ouais
ma maman c'est le futé exactement jeu
dans la série call bon après midi
oh lalala lalala vendu moselle futé
casimir leone avant pétantes
bonjour ma grosses cloches en chocolat
des îles la grosse cloche un chocolat au
lait aux normes entre toi fonds vont
m'en voulez pas moins futés non voyons
léonard c'est bien vrai c'est vrai
absolument exact pour comme ap le cul tu
as grosses cloches en chocolat désir
parce que casimir m'a dit que les
cloches volante allait faire une escale
ici spécialement dans l'île et nous on
laisserait tomber des oeufs dans les
buissons
est ce que c'est vrai maintenant c'est à
peu prés salés en a mais sais-tu d'où
vient cette coutume des oeufs de pâques
ah non je trouve que c'est une très
bonne habitude mais c'est tout ce que je
sais de son est bien autrefois pendant
le carême qui était d'une durée de 40
jours avant pâques
on n'avait pas la permission de manger
des canaris bleus coutu
alors on les mettait de côté on les
faisait cuire et puis on les payait en
rouge en verre en bleu
et puis le jour de pain cas dans chaque
famille on organisait une distribution
de décor et maintenant et maintenant on
voit que ce sont les cloches qui les
apportent et les enfants organisent
partout dans les villes dans les maisons
dans les jardins des grandes chasses aux
oeufs parce que naturellement les clans
jettent leur jeu par les fenêtres et il
intéresse dans les salons elle
naturellement
et naturellement il devrait y avoir une
clanche qui jette un grand panier 2 dans
ma main ici ah oui les renards mais ceci
laisse le couvercle de pas mal bien
ouverts et les oeufs ne vous tombe pas
sur le tâte jara alors vraiment ces
cloches de pâques sont très intelligent
très très intelligent bonjour ma chère
aide mais comment se porte notre
botaniste très très bien monsieur du
snav serono lama a aussi que malaxer les
vous lâche est raide mais bien c'est une
préparation spéciale pour 1,9 que
j'aurais pas pour casimir de la crème de
marrons de la choucroute du sucre des
piments rouges et un peu tard il a donné
beaucoup de mal dans ce gros balourd
enfin je vous laisse à votre cuisine à
plus tard non mais non mais non monsieur
je suis revenu oui oui vous n'êtes pas
censé ignorer que c'est bientôt pâques
oui je n'ignore pas évidemment bien
alors j'ai l'intention d'organiser une
grande chasse aux oeufs pour léonard
casimir et tous les ans à les enfants
sont ravis
c'est très bien ma chère nv oui alors
soyez gentils messieurs du stop donnez
moi un coup de main parce que j'aurai
patente ou filles ah bon mais je n'y
comprend absolument rien aux 9,2 pas que
vous avez mais si mais si tu tenais
asseyez-vous là vous allez voir c'est
très simple je dois les faire voilà vous
prenez tout c'est eux
oui voilà voilà oui les couleurs oui
voilà
et je pars et vous ping et vous croyez
que ce n'est pas déshonorant pour un
artiste peintre de faire ce travail là
mais non mais non pas du tout et quand
vous aurez terminé vous les placerait
dans ces petits ni la hadda comme voyez
web il a cité ne remplit calais cash
et puis en plus après toutes les colères
que vous avez eue contre casimir vous
lui devait bien ça j'ai jamais de colère
contre kazim jawad mais j'ai seulement
essayé de lui faire comprendre en
insistant un petit peu je lave ou de ne
pas prendre mais les oeuvres d'art pour
pour des petits fous c'est bien pour une
fois vous serai ravi qu'ils les mangent
la voilà on ça ira comme ça voilà voilà
vous avez terminé monsieur dû se
terminer bien
n'oubliez pas de conserver quelques
oeufs de compte frais pour léonard il ne
les aime qu'au naturel
[Musique]
saleh elles sont passées à l'éviter bon
alors léonard ouais tu vas à l'avant du
jardin et tu fouilles de kiosques et moi
je vais sur la gauche vers la cage à
poules et l'aube enfin d'accord on y va
martin ya j'en ai déjà un au diable ou
ainsi intentions vont aimer les enfants
hop encore un bon encore en ici 3,4 au
haut qu'il est gros celui là on l'a
elle devait être énorme c'est aux
cloches
voilà et dieu regarde léonard
j'en ai déjà si ça et vous les enfants
vous en avez trouvé beaucoup de voix
qu'il ressemble à aucun autre
ah non non léonard celui ci est pour moi
d'ailleurs il y à mon nom dessus ces
bonbons mais moi enfin j'aurais préféré
trouver une poule c'est encore meilleur
léonard tu m'avais promis de ne plus
jamais mangé de poule
d'ailleurs qu'il a une superbe
collection d'offres a gobé pendant ce
temps là je vais manger le mien et je
les prépare et spécialement benoît hamon
les messieurs ont vraiment alors tous
les deux vous êtes formidables est
patent époustouflant oui mais vous ne
devriez pas vous en tenir là ah bon que
nous dire eh bien pendant que nous
mangeons nozari mademoiselle futaie pour
vraiment préparé un second comme celui
ci aurait vous vous pourriez nous
chanter une chanson si l'occasion et
bien écoute casimir je vais t'étonner
j'accepte musique comme d'hab
[Musique]
m
j'ai chassé le lézard vert pendant trois
jours au congo j'ai jouer à saute pas
loin avec un chef des eskimos
je suis très snob chaque jour je colle
un gros oeuf d'autruche à mon petit
déjeuner j'ai chanté un opéra dans la
rue à tombouctou trouver les trésors
osaka dans un musée du pétrole
les gens s'arrachent mais au togo on m'a
reconnu dans un heureusement quartier
jeu
suis un champion dé la sculpture
je
fait lâcher de faisans peinture je suis
le plus grand le plus beau le plus fort
je connais le fils du frère de la
belle-soeur de marquis c'est un homme de
qualité la preuve c'est qu'il me l'a dit
il très snob
comme moi il colle un gros atout truchat
son petit déjeuner
il sait parler se tressent nord avec un
accent anglais
moi j'y arrive
mieux avec la somme à payer
j'ai du talent c'est évident de toute ma
rue je suis la célébrité jeu
suis un champion de la sculpture
pour eux
je
peu de chefs d'oeuvre de peinture je
suis le plus grand le plus beau le plus
fort mais il m'arrive quelquefois de
faire rentrer un peu fou je m'appelle
monsieur durand et j'ai les mêmes eaux
que
jeanne supplice mort alors je colle
un petit oeuf de poule qui me rend tour
des primaires
matin quand je m'éveille j'oublie mon
rêve et c'est bien
je vois ma canne mon chapeau et mon
costume italien
je redeviens ce nom alors je colle un
gros oeuf d'autruche à mon p'tit déj
[Musique]
o na un poussin